Howie Mandel here hey what's up Jerry
Ferrara is Jim Breuer I'm Theo von I'm
Joey hi my name is Chad Daniels anyway
what I'm doing right here is I'm gonna
answer the Internet here's my first
question from the internet
Thank You Internet okay if you had to
pick one person to be the ambassador for
the human race to meet aliens who would
it be
I don't know that he's still alive but
Marcel Marceau like a mime don't you
think it would be great like it would be
easier to anybody who does mine when
they say take me to your leader I want
them to go what's going on here and then
explain and then you wait and then you
Excel explain that you know sometimes
from time to time we get trapped in a
box or it gets windy down here so we
need a rope so they'll understand this I
think that a mime would make the
communication and the understanding of
the human race so much easier than any
spokesperson go ahead
would you rather prove aliens are real
or prove ghosts are real I would rather
prove aliens are real cuz I don't know I
just feel like that's talked about way
more and with their like storm area 50 I
just feel like that it's very current
and good to go I'd much rather prove
aliens are real yes
would you rather prove aliens are real
that's she likes aliens or approved
ghosts are real ghosts aliens why what
ghosts are real like we don't then you
know that you're gonna you're not gonna
you're gonna be dead and meet somewhere
else
even aliens it's like there's [ __ ] I
ain't gonna be space ship
I'm not going up to the station aliens
first shirks I'm gonna get the [ __ ]
outta Mexico
would you rather prove aliens are real
or prove ghosts are real oh man I could
not give a [ __ ] really
yeah I thought I'd I'm not an alien or a
ghost guy I mean it would be fun okay
I do have an answer I would rather prove
aliens are real just for all the kids I
went to high school with that shoved God
down my throat and up my [ __ ] at the
same time yeah I would rather prove
aliens are real to be like Oh guess what
would you rather prove aliens are real
or prove ghosts are real well I have my
own conspiracies but I'd rather prove
that ghosts are real oh here we go
uh I don't think we're alone in this
universe I I don't I think it's it's
it's you know for us to think we're the
only ones that happen to be around
that's no bad yeah even Ohio has has
people that love their mom we're not
alone people we're not alone if you had
to pick one person to be the ambassador
for the human race to meet aliens who
would it be
people pick one person it was like a fun
you know an affront you you know you
guys talk about Henry Winkler is he is
here he would be a good person to like
he's that you're like that's like yeah
that's like us man we're like fun you
know he used to be real cool he could
show videos of being like here's what
the evolution of what we do become to
him down the pond if you had to pick one
person to be the ambassador for the
human race to meet aliens a Joe Rogan if
you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens who would it be
oh this is good a probably Pig probably
a Filipino dude I'm really impact rate
about Filipinos they're happy they're
joyous you know they call them the
smiling people somewhere on the Internet
and and every Filipino I meet their real
gracious they do a lot of senior care
centers hospice so you don't [ __ ] who
else you're gonna send out there dude
you know what I'm saying
a [ __ ] drunk you know uh somebody
from Scotland know somebody owned coke
you can't do any of that you got to send
somebody who is caring I think oh you
mean like a specific person Manny
Pacquiao yeah maybe Manny Pacquiao
you